Politics affects everyone and the best way for citizens to affect politics is by voting.
Although it is easier to criticize our politicians than to praise them,...
...it's important to remember we elected them.
Ideally, we elect people who will faithfully represent us at both the local and national level...
...and we have only ourselves to blame if they don't.
Some of the issues that affect citizens and their decision to vote...
...for certain candidates are based on local issues.
People may want more parks nearby.
People living in cities may want more or less development in their neighborhood.
Others want improvement in air quality or less industry in their area.
Finally, some citizens may want improved city services and a more responsive government.
At the national level, citizens may want a stronger national defense...
...or more international prestige and power for Korea.
Citizens and other groups may want to see improvement in the education system.
Laborers and unions may want the minimum wage to rise or see other types of labor reform.
Businesses and the wealthy may want their taxes reduced.
In short, every citizen or citizen group wants something.
To get what we want, it's up to us to elect those who will work for us...
...and to vote out of office those who don't.
It is often said that citizens get the government they deserve.
Don't we deserve better?